[Applaudissements]
le 26 mai 1969 dans la chambre 1742 de
l'hôtel reine elizabeth de montréal john
lennon et yoko ono lors ce message de
paix cinquante ans plus tard le célèbre
bed-in revit dans une exposition
intitulée l'art de john et yoko il
fallait aller plus loin mettre ça en
contexte avec une pratique artistique
qui est aussi axé sur l'action
participation pour rendre l'expérience
vivante ce voyage dans le temps offre un
condensé de témoignages du légendaire
événements si on ouvre on peut découvrir
le récit de jerry du tout qui est un
photographe américain
elle a fait une connexion tellement
profond de john et yoko qu'il était le
seul photographe est invité à rester
contre les jours on y retrouve aussi des
photos inédites parmi les 1000 clichés
immortaliser des dessins faits à la main
par le couple et la mythique chanson
believe the chains enregistré par le
producteur québécois andré perry on a
toute une salle où les gens peuvent
écouter son récit et écouter les
chansons telles qu'il les a enregistré
un autre volet de l'exposition est
consacrée uniquement aux oeuvres créées
par yoko ono sur un petit carton juste à
côté de l'oeuvre
on donne la marche à suivre les
instructions vient de très loin dans sa
pratique où elle voulait vraiment
dépassé les limites de des disciplines
street
elle est conservée une grande pionnière
pour l'art conceptuel l'art
contemporaine c'est d'ailleurs cette
oeuvre qui à londres en 1966 a intrigué
john n est là essayez-le il a grimpé sur
les chalets il a voulu en savoir plus
sur l'artiste et le reste appartient
aujourd'hui à l'histoire
ici julie jasmin goudreau radio canada
montréal
[Applaudissements]